how you doing people welcome to the
Rubin report I am Dave Rubin that is
Chad I'm binder and who she Kelly Carlin
alright I guess we have a show let's do
it okay we had another beheading video
from Isis steven sotloff who is an
american journalist have you to gain for
your actions to get another American
citizen so just as your massage
continues to strike our people our knife
will continue to strike the necks of
your people because of your insistence
in continuing your bonds in our lives in
modern the Mosul Dam despite our serious
warnings you Obama have yet again for
your actions could get another American
citizen so just as your massage seems to
strike our people our knife will
continue to strike the neck okay so we
obviously didn't show the beheading
itself there YouTube's taking the videos
down Twitter is banning people that post
it but I wanted to at least get you guys
the message on that this of course comes
about two weeks after they did the same
exact things to James Foley another
American photojournalist and supposedly
now they have a British journalist that
they plan on doing this to end and
apparently there's about 20 other people
that they have being held hostage right
now I mean we've been doing this every
week now you've been tweeting a lot
about this just this sort of savagery
that we're seeing how do we make any
sense of what's going on over there well
this is the way I've been thinking about
it lately
I mean it's horrific and it's it stopped
me in my tracks and even when the video
came up in the studio here I like I
don't even want to like I don't want to
see the whole situation
trigger warning like you know all that
kind of stuff but and this is gonna tie
into a future topic we've got going
today but basically this shit's been
going on a long [ __ ] time and the
fact that we way we now have it
videotape and high production value I
want to add that's kind of the creepiest
part of all of this but this has been
going on in humanity for tens of
thousands of years or at least I don't
know but at least a couple of thousands
years with civilization and
war and empires and all that so it's
horrific and it's insane and yet welcome
to the human species I don't know what
to say it's it's just like I it's just
so much for me yeah so let's just talk
about the video themselves do we have to
show these things because you know when
Twitter banned all the people for
putting up the video I kind of think you
have to have access to it so we know
what's going on of course you don't want
to push out their propaganda and all
that but what do you think about just
showing the videos themselves because
some people do want to see the the part
that we didn't show there well I I would
never want to see the part that they
didn't show I mean I have enough
imagination left to fill in that
horrific blonde oh yeah
but I think you have to have access to
you know has to has to be some form of a
free media you have to show these things
to educate and inform yeah so that's a
great point so you show it in a
situation where you are educating and
informing but just having it loose on
the internet for and and bless you
youtuber comments commenters for
youtuber commenters to talk about you
know how gay he is and sucking his dick
or something I don't know that that
worries me
you know people using it to discuss
geopolitical situations terrorism trauma
whatever it is yeah sure but I don't
know I don't think people should be
tweeting this [ __ ] all right so that
being said let's not get too hung up on
the beheadings themselves but apparently
Isis is actually much bigger than we
thought we've got some interesting info
here so two quotes here the first one is
from a security expert in Baghdad he
said the Islamic state didn't come from
nowhere it's an extension of groups that
existed before historically and
ideologically okay that's not major news
the second one here from a political
analyst in Jordan I thought was the
interesting one the Islamic states
members have multiplied in a very
dangerous way having plenty of arms and
funding has made Isis swallow the
fighters of other Sunni insurgents so
basically they're just combining all
these groups that we funded half of them
and the ones that we didn't fund now
they have their weapons now they're
saying there's about a hundred thousand
of them two weeks ago they thought there
was 40,000 of them
there's tons of British people like the
guy who who did the beheading in that
video is this one of these things where
the u.s. is just damned if we do damned
if we don't if we go in more people hate
us we don't do anything more people get
killed but nobody else is gonna do
anything so we're just it's almost like
trying to invade Coachella
you took Coachella and Burning Man and
had them attack each other and then
whatever was left over those people
became Isis I'm actually with you on
this and I really think that if we think
about it in the raw numbers of a hundred
thousand that's where we can we can
target and have a strategy like hundred
thousand people that's about 750
porta-potties six service so we just
look for a caravan of porta-potties bomb
the s out of that gets my kids are
watching yeah you know seriously I think
that's that's we're looking at yeah yeah
going with I mean what do we do do we by
now everyone seems to be for bombing me
you know no troops but just send some
hugs how did this all well how did this
mess start 12 years ago yeah because we
bombed Iraq that's how this mess started
look when you take dictators like Saddam
Hussein and Assad and Syrian people like
that who are like really rule with an
iron fist these tribal regions and you
remove them you get a lot of tribal
energy and blood and beheading and [ __ ]
like that goes on this you know the
scary thing is these people have access
to money and arms and you know things
like that now and bigger things and
hopefully not dirty bombs and [ __ ] like
that I'm hoping that they there the
infighting will start because it always
does with these groups inviting Astarte
yeah and inviting even in the ISIS will
start and then but also when I watched a
video I don't anyone saw this of an
Iraqi TV show they still have them there
believe it or not with some Arab
gentleman and Arab headdresses I don't
know if that makes I think that makes
them Sunni
and I'm not not an expert in any of this
they were sitting around talking about
the the the Christian community in some
of these cities and how they're being
targeted and one of these men in full
Arab headdress began weeping for his
Christian friends and I was like hope
hope hope hope hope so there's a lot of
humanity left in these countries a lot
of humanity in the population we need to
support those people yeah with ways to
combat these bad people but so how do
you support humanity right like everyone
agrees with that right that sounds good
we have to support humanity humanity's
not usually supported by bombs it's ugly
you know nobody gets their house bombed
you know there will be bombing yeah
we'll be killing yeah what about the
rest of the world why is it always us is
it because everyone knows that we're
sort of addicted to intervention like
they know that they don't have to do
anything like really England frantic
this is what we do but doesn't show man
where the Superman country what doesn't
it show like sort of what a farce the UN
and NATO and everything really is
because at the end of the day it's about
us whether we like it or not well it's
about I think whoever has the most toys
and the most money but but that's right
and the best Doc Martens I mean our
boots will be on the ground again in
that area do you really yeah well
supposedly this morning Obama sent 350
more troops that's obviously nothing but
it's it's something yeah charge of
finding those porta-potties yeah yeah
yeah all right so last thought on this
and then we'll move on to some happier
stuff but with all these reports about
all this stuff and now you know Rick
Perry not that I like to quote Rick
Perry but he's saying they're coming
through the border in Mexico and today
they found this guy in yeah that's what
he's saying and they got this guy in in
Minnesota who was working for Delta who
apparently left to go fight for Isis so
it's something gonna happen here I mean
we're in evitable right like it's just
inevitable it's time to invade Texas if
they're coming through Mexico at all I'm
not looking at you Austin yeah that's a
reverse except if you give someone
that's reversing yeah oh yeah okay
piss off Isis try to give them Texas
yeah then they'll be pissed yeah what do
you think though I mean is it's
inevitable like something yeah you
there's no way they can protect us from
every single possible a little bit of it
I mean no matter how many shoes they
check at the airport yeah I think I mean
we have to be vigilant and yet there's
too many people there's too many ways to
travel there's too many forests to climb
through something something will happen
and that's frightening and scary and I
think there's the parallels from history
I mean that's one of the things I really
respect about you is your ability to
remember stuff and I'm not talking about
for breakfast tomorrow or yesterday but
you know if you look at the first world
war and what happened there with with
the Huns you know with the Germany and
then how that set the stage for the sons
of that yeah not unlike we're hearing
that it's it's xpath Assad on military
guys and their sons when I heard that
I'm like oh oh so this becomes around
the the communal fire whether that be a
stove or an actual fire it's they're
remembering how their days of glory and
they're passing that anger and that
desolation and that lack of opportunity
to their sons who are now joining a
movement which ended up becoming a right
right and you know in Germany in the 30s
there's a lot of parallels that when you
decimate a culture and you don't fly
over that culture and drop a bunch of
Sears and Roebuck catalog so they can
see how to rebuild yeah what will fill
that void is usually anger vehemence and
yeah well as I think I've said every
week we should be dropping PlayStation
stead of bombs and then maybe they'd
have something to do or porn or what
else she wanted people do porn
PlayStation got anything else with P pop
popcorn potato chips potato chips there
you go we've solved the Middle East okay
let's move on
president obama did four fundraisers
last week a lot of people giving him
[ __ ] for all the fundraisers and the
golf and all that stuff I don't want to
focus on that but he had an interesting
quote about everything that's been going
on
and the media's relation to making us
all crazy let's take a look he said I
can see why a lot of folks are troubled
the world's always been messy we're just
noticing now in part because of social
media if you watch the nightly news it
feels like the world is falling apart
but it's been challenging for quite a
while we will get through these
challenging times just like we have in
the past
okay now I'm sort of on board with a
little of that right I mean we see all
this stuff now we see the beheadings
immediately we don't have to wait for
the nightly news we get all the videos
all that stuff on the other hand the
media's been pretty soft on the guy so
it seems like it's a little disingenuous
- it's not about being soft on Obama
it's what the media feeds the public and
how they shape what's going on in the
world and this is communications 101
stuff right the media has a bias their
job is to if it bleeds it leads
and if it's if there's any kind of drama
if there's a need for Superman to come
along to solve something they will put
that on the TV and so completely we are
inundated and so you have the nightly
news which has always been horrific I
mean if you live to the Vietnam era
Nightly News was pretty grim Nixon
Vietnam all that kind of stuff all the
way through but now you have the echo
chamber now everybody's putting it on
their Facebook wall in there is this and
my opinion to this and tweeted it it's
so it feels like the same news story
you're now seeing it probably 10 or a
hundred times a day yeah it affects the
brain
so does it affect your brain because I
definitely think it does Kelly and I
have talked about this a lot that you're
constantly if you have your phone and
your and your Twitter and we're gonna
talk about this later also but if you
have this stuff yours being slammed by
this information repeatedly so does
Obama at least have a point there that
it maybe seems worse now just because of
the accident you mean like that the
media is turned into AM radio it's that
you know since since the hostage crisis
between you know Reagan and Carter when
they went to the 24-hour news cycle it's
now basically Billy don't be a hero
except it's Billy don't blow up or
behead anybody in the in the Middle East
I mean they their objectivity gone their
impartiality gone their bar their bought
and paid for is what's their the 24-hour
news
is just beating us to death like AM
radio can make you like Katrina and the
waves walking on sunshine I actually
have that song in my head from 1987
because of the repetition which is now a
part of our news needs right you got to
just keep that song going just so you
can get through the day yeah I mean if
you're on the right and you're watching
fox or if you're on the left and you're
watching MSNBC you're basically a star
Belly's nature is or a sneech without a
star but you're just cranking the same
15 minutes and it goes from each talking
head right and if you lived before this
period of time you realize that that's
not what the media the news is supposed
to be yeah it bleeds it leads was not
part of the problem yeah you know it's
that it bleeds it leads brought to you
by dial you know for a manly wash of the
blood that's all over your hands now
yeah this is we talk about this all the
time they look if you turn on Fox you're
getting Republican parties you if you
turn on MSNBC you're getting the
administration so you turn on CNN
they're putting up just people on both
sides but then there's no analysis they
don't tell you what the truth is they
just put up PR guys on both sides so I
go okay so we're all with Holograms the
Holograms are good though I like the
holiday will be doing this by Holograms
by next year all right so I get it we
all leave so we all hate the media okay
media sucks we're all on board that
theory but is there still something a
little is it possible that what he's
saying is true and not true so the media
sucks we're all on board that but then
is it possible that things are worse now
but we can't possibly can't filter it
properly because of all that this
nonsense don't think seem a little worse
now like there's so much [ __ ] going on
between Ukraine and Gaza and Syria and
Iraq and Ebola and like is it possible
that things maybe are worse yeah there
is a lot going on and what is a lot and
I think there's always a lot going on
and and we are just so interconnected
now there's there's very few walls
between towns nations villages and
there's no walls and and so we're just
it's a lot of information and yes maybe
it's a little bit of a spike of
horribleness and it yes I mean it's been
a bad month it feels like it's been a
bad month you know and
and it's difficult but this is where I
think education the education system
really needs to change media literacy
needs to start in kindergarten yeah kids
need to learn that when they go to a
website or they turn on a channel or
they're looking at a Twitter feed that
someone is saying something based on an
opinion there's you know that unless
you're a scientist in reading a science
paper which is bias in it because it's a
human there is a bias going on people
want to sell you their there's their
side of things so I think the perception
is reality you know I think things are
worse and I have the perspective of time
and in a different news cycle and a
different repetition a different
frequency repetitive frequency of a news
story I believe that things are worse
and I think that what you're asking for
to teach the children does happen my
daughter had an assignment when she was
in grade school which dealt with
Wikipedia as a source and how dangerous
that could be and the teacher actually
went through and told everybody to use
Wikipedia for this this paper they were
writing and then went through and
dispelled but some idiot just put up a
FAQ
you know no Isis is not being led by
Sacha Baron Cohen it would be even
though he sounds like that guy either
you can't read that on wiki and take it
as a fact but it does come back to this
thing about the media in that they've
lost their credibility so we have the
frequency you know it's it's a brisket
without the meat which is basically a
bone we're boned you know we don't have
anybody being object I mean shows like
this and other shows are in certain
markets the online world can have some
reality to it but even there you have
another person or entity just frequency
throwing lies and and factoids which are
non facts yeah so until we can figure
out a way to get that objectivity back
and get the the profit center out of
news out of media which is really the
problem we're gonna be in trouble we're
gonna be all chasing the wrong facts
over and over and over every 15 minutes
on the hour so to that point last
question on this I kind of feel like
because we don't trust the media
because we don't trust our politicians
I've been feeling lately I think it's
sort of kicked in over the summer that
we kind of don't know what America is
anymore like there's a real feeling
amongst amongst I'm not talking about
the left and the right but like pretty
much everybody else which is most of us
even though they make it seem like the
rational people only a tiny bit it's
most of us I think that we don't we just
don't know what we are anymore like are
we the intervention is are we the
peaceniks are we do you feel that - yeah
and even even more than that like more
than policy it's like who what you know
the institutions are all going away who
do we trust yous got who's got the facts
who's got of just a real rational
perspective on anything we don't trust
government we don't trust big business
we don't trust media we don't trust you
know we don't trust anyone and so we're
having to find our own kind of energy PS
with all of this and I think that's part
of feeding all of the frenzy - is like
you know we're looking for information
I'm willing to give you more information
and I think it's a natural outcome of
modern society the breakdown of of
institutions what's going on and I you
know we're in the middle of it we're in
the middle of the chaos of all of this
yeah trying to end this on a positive
note is there something good out of that
could something good come out of us
having to sorta recenter ourselves
because if we don't trust the
institutions we have to trust ourselves
give me something oh absolutely
absolutely and there's an app for it I'm
gonna pull it up now we're the term
[ __ ] at birth was was gonna be
actually come true that was it's hard
it's hard and I'm anyone else you have
kids I have kids no kids yeah no it
Arnel it's brutal
I cannot even project what their life
will be based on all of the stuff that
we're being fed by the media and all of
the awareness that we thought we were
post-racial telling that hand better be
about hope yeah what you want to be
positive
hear about all the good [ __ ] happening
you have to you what to fight for you
have to look for it but there's a lot of
good stuff happening people are treating
people well science is doing great
things business is doing great things
government people are doing great things
there are good people out there there's
still humanity that's that's a that's a
load of crap people you should change
the channel right now to somebody that
will tell you that the world is going to
hell in a handbasket okay all right you
have my permission to hate this woman's
hope okay because it's not happening no
look she's right there are there are
good things happening they don't get
enough frequency they don't get enough
bandwidth
I think we've woken up here's the
positive message we all stood there in
that Park with Obama you know
metaphorically we thought wow this is
gonna be a step forward and we then I
spent the next six years going wow seven
steps back but you know in like a
football analogy once you get sacked you
dust yourself off and you go onto the
next play like we have to now belly up
to the bar and if you can't wait you
know it can't be this thing about
waiting for my kids to solve it we have
to hand them something we have to fix
something in the now so that the next
generation is really clueless can figure
out how to move forward
all right you ended me on a positive
note I appreciate it from Isis and the
government now let's talk about the
serious there is a new iPhone coming and
it's going to be announced by Apple in
just a couple days on September 9th and
my inside source is yahoo.com tell me
that it's going to be released the 4.7
inch will be released on September 19th
don't quote me on that but that's what
they're telling me now we can go to the
wide shot because we all have our you
guys even painted Isis killed the 5.5
yeah
okay so we've all got these things so we
fully admit it we have three iPhone
people here at that an iPad I've got a
MacBook which I knocked the glass of
water on this week and then my blow
dried and which ended up melting the
keyboard but I still have a MacBook you
got a MacBook I know use Mac since 1984
all right so you're in it sign on early
Chad you have a MacBook or an apple or
you on PC what I am a Mac guy I've okay
spent millions of dollars on Apple
suppository
so you have
the facts we have all fest up we're in
it we're yes with the Apple products now
I want to show you there's a couple
leaked images of the iPhone 6 so let's
just take a look real quick it's gonna
be thinner
that's right it's gonna be thinner so
what you're seeing there is the outside
back of the case let's look at the shot
of the casing oh wow thinner sexy isn't
that thing sexy look at that thing look
at the bottom oh I just can't three
times look at the front of the screen oh
and apparently that would be sapphire
glass which is very hard to break yeah
okay so yeah Apple Apple blah blah blah
we all know it we kind of love it we
hate it so that's where I want to start
with this thing do you guys sort of feel
like slaves to Apple because that is how
I feel like when my MacBook broke a
couple days ago I had just been at Apple
because my phone the audio stopped
working and I can only use it on speaker
and when I was in there for that I kept
thinking is this my chance to get out
but then I was like I got a MacBook at
home do I have to make Samsung I guess
but with this yeah yeah or that you can
go to know who makes computers now to
delegate I've got a new guy who works on
my apples at home and he used to work
for the NSA and he says everyone in the
government has apples basically everyone
they make them special for the
government workers for CIA everyone in
the world is working on these machines
now so this is good or bad I'm just
saying that you know no I'm saying that
if you want the best OS and the most
efficient machine these things tend to
do better than the other ones and I know
for a fact that the Samsung people in
the comments right now we're gonna blow
up because every time we do something
Pro Apple they go we got the other end
if you have Samsung bless you and and
have fun with it and it does all the
same things this does because this
invented it oh yeah I think we should
all fear Apple yeah I think Apple is
ultimately a George Orwellian nightmare
coming you know because then it'll be
know that the product can we keep
hearing like the product in the pipeline
we've got 10 years of product you know
what let me tell everybody something
Steve Jobs is dead
okay all right time to move on people
until I start seeing an i liver and an
eye eye and an eye ear and an eye and an
i : you know that would no balls
everything is my balls went right over
York later Apple will be the new Isis
that's my prediction
Apple will take over what that mean it
means that you know you're gonna be
loving this corporation that eventually
becomes so powerful it becomes a nation
so haven't they become everything that
they fought against cuz George Orwell I
mean they did that their will they of
course we mean that's that's like edie
mainstream culture takes the edge it
stimulates it and makes it the
mainstream that's what happens but it's
worse it's worse because and we've
talked about this you're going to be so
locked into something like Apple that at
a certain point you can't get out so you
have to do small things to resist it
like my let my big computer die I had it
for six years which is unheard of an
apple time I mean my dad was an early
adopter he had a my dad you know did Doc
you know documents and email on his
computer he had the towers with all the
computing you know you can you can go to
the moon and back with this tower every
year he got a new one when the new one
came out I don't do that I resist our
resistor is this I've had a crack in my
screen like the powers over a year no
not getting a new one not getting it
fixed screw you I'm walking around with
a crack I'm okay with my crack yeah
that's the novice that I already have
somebody waiting in line for that five
point five iPhone you know why because I
was cursed with on good clothes over
there's Andre the Giant sighs folks so
doing this on this device I want it you
know if they don't release that 5.5 I
want to tell you I'm driving up to
Cupertino and I am punching that guy in
the dick it's gonna be three sizes
that's my image you know it's two sizes
and it's not a 5.5 somebody's getting a
dick it's it's big just for the visual
we should know that you have a smart car
which is one of those tiny little cars
so if you were to get the five point I
mean that your phone would be bigger
than your [ __ ] phone ride shotgun
doesn't have to call it just put it
right there
alright last thought on Apple so you
know they're building this giant
fortress in Cupertino it sort of looks
like the Pentagon although not sure it's
round but it's got like that feeling of
a fortress so to your point so or trous
or when is I mean really we need Apple
has more money than the US government
they have liquid assets and they are
just churning out money money money yes
when will companies truly surpass the
government I mean have they already like
well who's the gentleman the Eric Cantor
this week where did he go
he went to Wall Street yeah no there's
no government is is not this biggest
thing at all
big business has way more power and I
like I think it'll be fun the Apple
fortress will be fun I'll be like a
Hunger Games kind of a thing maybe you
know they have like fun things in the
middle and people be killing each other
feel like I Thunderdome I hope in future
and we just have to play along which is
why yes I talk about this all the time
but I probably will get it cuz I don't
want to fall behind in whatever the
future may Oh Joey falling behind people
when the thumb war I can't wait that'll
be five point five all right so an
interesting
speaking of iPhones and all this
technology so an interesting study came
out from UCLA studying student student
social skills related to smartphones and
all this technology so it's a little
technical here so I'm gonna read it the
UCLA psychology department looked at two
groups of eleven to twelve year olds
half the students spend five days at a
nature and science camp where digital
technology was strictly taboo could not
do any of this the participants were
forced to interact with each other talk
face-to-face it was crazy it was old
school they were all shown photographs
of people and asked to state whether the
emotions expressed in the photographs
were happy sad angry or frightened they
were then shown videos and asked to
describe what was happening in the
simple scenarios okay I think you could
follow along there now let's look at the
findings during the research one group
made significantly more progress than
the other the group deprived of all
digital media
even television performs significantly
better at recognizing emotions than
those who allowed to keep texting and
tweeting and talking on Facebook after
just five days I've got a quote from the
researcher he said many people are
looking at the benefits of digital media
in education and not many are looking at
the cost decreased sensitivity to
emotional cues losing the ability to
understand the emotions of other people
is one of the cost so let's stop there
for a second let's just talk about that
now we just did the segment on iPhones
and the addiction to this thing and all
that I see this every day in life every
day I'm walking around and I admit you
guys know how much I tweet so I'm not
putting it out there and I'm dude we're
doing this on YouTube and we're all on
Facebook and all that but I see this
constantly now people walking down
walking like this literally crashing
into [ __ ] people this you're talking to
someone literally making eye contact
with them and saying something important
and then they immediately and then just
in the middle they just start doing this
talking to my daughter it looks like
yeah yeah how old's your daughter with
they're both well one is 23 yeah and the
other one is 19 okay so they're a little
a little ahead of these in age but
certainly younger than well have used I
mean do you see this every day in your
life this endless like lack of attention
people forgetting things you can you can
you feel it at a social setting which
you know the three of us have been
together but you know when we're all
like the phones are away and it's
everything and we're just connecting and
it's really great everything and the
minute one person takes yes the phone
out it gives permission to everyone else
of the thing like okay well check the
email order and now there's like a
silence comes over and you can feel the
disconnect and then when everyone puts
it away it takes a moment to like oh we
were reading like this the it's the
whole other part of the animal mind
comes forward oh okay that's right
connection social cues yeah it's I find
that to be just the energy that happens
in a room that's just the shift around
people around that I fascinating yeah we
did a story on how it literally is
rewiring people's brains because you're
not supposed to be inundated with
information constantly and we're
actually changing how we I just heard a
social scientist talk about this on
another show
and he said you know actually evolution
of this kind of stuff yes is a rewiring
of the brain but a real evolution takes
about a thousand years for the species
just be speeding it up because I've seen
that type of studies too and that maybe
they don't think so I mean in the short
term it's definitely affecting things
but it's not actually evolving but you
know we'll see it feel honestly true
story my daughter just went back down to
school for her second year of college
because I have money to grow I mean I
literally in the way into studio I was
just Chuck and fives everybody I walked
by so we're talking and it's you know
I'm very much the daddy-daughter thing
you know it's like okay well this is
your second year and you know I know
you're switching majors and like
literally four sentences in brought up
the phone and you know looked at me and
was like and I it was all I could do
it's all I could really well to not just
start beating or definitely the phone
which is why the 5.5 iPhone is really
gonna work for me because I mean I can
do it in less hits it's just it's a part
of their Norman culture I have a picture
of the same kid you want an iMac the
original the one that was like a like an
old TV with you know mousing around on
some game some learning game some Mavis
Beacon teaches typing [ __ ] she's
like five with the bottle her like
bottle and she's just like it we've lost
this generation to whatever this digital
nightmare is I mean it's a nightmare
that they are so we and we almost cured
a Dede and then the Apple helped us
break it but it'll be fascinating
because I think what'll come into the
culture and there'll be a new need in
the culture is people to create space
and circumstance and opportunity and
teach people to have emotional
intelligence again which I'm excited
about because that's what I love to do
that is your thing well you've actually
given me a perfect segue here because
comedian Patton Oswald you guys probably
heard about this he took three months
basically the entire summer off of
social media and he explained why in a
Time magazine article that came out this
week in part he said what if the next
fashionable rebellion from whatever
generation rears its head after the
Millennials is to become unlinked only
reachable face-to-face hmm remember how
in the matrix mankind had become
batteries so the machines could just
feed off us well it's happening now just
a hundred 40 words at a time I remember
when I got out of college 99 I was
having a conversation with a friend of
mine we were on a bus somewhere and we
were talking about the meaning of life
the whole thing I was smoking a lot of
pot at the time and I told him
everything I thought about life and he
goes dude you just told me the plot to
the matrix but I hadn't seen the matrix
but that's what I was but that's what I
was talking about that we are one day
just gonna be batteries for this it's
gonna become that important because this
needs us to just we make 100 watts of
energy yeah in each body so there you go
we're already about so it's gonna run
the 5.5 that might that's gonna be the
problem you really change again if we go
tight on these thumbs you know this is
my cross to bear oh yeah yeah look at
that that's it there's I could eat four
of those on the hour and it's still
wouldn't equal this toe toe jam that's
happening right here it's a giant phone
yeah a giant thumb you're welcome
America well we know we're making the
gif out of this week for the show what
do you think though this unlinked idea
that's what you're talking about that
that maybe these this next generation
after you know we had the nude hack this
week and the NSA we're all so sick of it
and yet we love it but we're also
signature that maybe the next generation
is kind of gonna be like but how will we
tell everyone were unlinking yeah yeah
terrific
such a great guy is such a great
comedian but I read that whole article
he was like I took three months off but
I checked in on Facebook I learned and I
didn't do any theater but I you know
like some of my friends things that were
doing Kickstarter IndieGoGo
so I'm like okay so we took three months
off or we just kind of lurked for three
months and that's what he did so what's
the point the point is is that we are in
a digital quicksand yeah and those of us
that are old enough you know sorry to
sound like that guy but I remember the
analog rim you know it's analog if we
don't get back to some form of analog
and meeting with people like the poly
yeah you know getting together
face-to-face and lessening the amount of
times where people pull their stupid
phone
check their stupid what Evers we're in
big trouble
yeah it's generational and the next
generation is not gonna without
something major like you know the
inability to be able to transmit because
our networks out electricity going away
it's not gonna get better
so slightly what you're doing with the
poly because because I think it's really
cool and it's one of the things that by
me being in LA has allowed me to put
this down because I don't do this when
I'm there so can you just explain a
little bit of what you're doing I just
I've been lucky enough to have an
incredible group of artists and people
come into my life
comedians musicians writers people like
you and we hang out we have you know we
meet once a month or so very casual
party atmosphere and we just connect we
just connect we don't we don't we have
all these and yes we'll bring it out we
need to Google something because we do
that but it is it's it's a connection of
people and but even the name itself poly
mind okay yeah so the poly mind came
about because I you know we have all
these voices in our head and I have all
the voices in my head and I originally
made it as like a blog kind of a title
the poly mind commune is the thing in my
head and and what it is is it it is its
diversity its diversity of perspective
its diversity of people and it's it's
what makes the world go round actually
and and you know part of this is that
this when we've been talking about the
whole show lack of diversity happens
through this because you pick your
Twitter feed you pick your friends on
Facebook and you pick a pick what
channel your news from so you know and
there's something about just hanging out
with people and getting to know people
it's been courting because people don't
understand what's happening because
they're digital they don't understand
the lack of humanity the loss of human
connection I mean in all sincerity if
you ever wanted to say you wanted to
date somebody you called a girl up on
the phone that still was an analog
moment because she was hearing your
voice and trying to figure out how to
get off the phone as fast as possible
with texting you can be led down that
path for longer because this digital
thing is almost a Santa it's like
sanitizing your interactions so when we
kind of get together as a group like if
you go out to dinner with two other
couples or whatever you think oh well
that's social that's face-to-face but
that is such a small microcosm of what's
necessary to combat what's going on in
our society you've got to get together
in groups hopefully without the try
pointed hats and you know and flip ya
and meet people and bounce from person
to person as opposed to from webpage or
Twitter feed a Twitter feed there's
something we're losing and we're losing
our analog social skills losing it
learning to look in a person's eyes when
you have a conversation and to feel okay
about that is God your eyes are so right
[Laughter]
that's what that's what that's that
study is talking about those kids are
not learning those skills so then 2530
years down the line how do when you have
two warring sides of two countries come
together to sit in a room to have to
find some common ground and you can't
even really look each other in the eye
one tweet to rule them all I think
that's a great way to wrap it up is we
even see this now with our political
leaders you know Rwanda and Iran
tweeting at the State Department they're
- but it's like guys maybe in a room do
you like this everyone thinks it's so
great look they're tweeting at each
other it's the greatest thing ever but
actually it's totally totally
meaningless alright let's move on and
talk about lesbian obesity we can't do a
week without lesbian obesity the federal
government spent about three million
dollars on a study to find out why a lot
of lesbians are obese don't believe me
well we've got some info the NIH study
is now in its fourth year the project
seeks to determine why quote nearly
three-quarters of adult lesbians are
overweight or obese and why gay males
are not the study is slated to last
until 2016 and the total funding for the
project is just about three million
dollars so I don't want to focus on why
lesbians are obese unless quickly you
want to
do you have no none of us are lesbians
here well I'm I'm not gonna blame Obama
but I am gonna blame the glute okay so I
don't want to focus on on that part of
it but I thought this brought up an
interesting point about just what the
government is spending money on and just
kind of what we let them spend money on
and what we don't know they're spending
money
I don't know this study in particular
but I'm gonna defend science which is
you know when you take a certain
population and you study it you're
trying to remove some factors around it
to make it easier to have your findings
have a little more purity to them
studying people who have a different
genetic makeup or different I mean you
know of course people want to believe
that lesbians a choice of a lifestyle
but it's it's clearly it's a nature
thing it's not a nurture thing so I
think it's legitimate I think it's
legitimate they're probably studying the
difference between testosterone and
estrogen levels and things like that and
gender I think it's fascinating and I
think it'll it'll it'll pan out it'll
create a lot of information for the
general population but you know they
have they're studying a very small slice
yeah okay so I'm glad you said that
because yes I do believe in science
funding and I don't understand all the
reasons why we do all these studies but
there's probably some relation there but
when I see these things I think the
average person when they see this in the
news they immediately think this is like
we need you know consultants to come in
to the government and be like what the
[ __ ] are you guys doing what really
lesbian oh you know they like is it just
is this just one of these things that
just sounds so ridiculous so that even
if there is scientific worth to it it's
it's gonna get [ __ ] the key word is
funding you know and I read the whole
article and I love the lower the
lesbians they quoted a what they would
call I guess a scientific outcome of
this was lower athletic self-esteem the
lesbians have low which which is
complete [ __ ] if you know any
lesbians they're awesome in sports and
most and most board games
it's good if board games to icon
softball with lesbian well for rugby
they're women so so they're smart and
Jane Lynch kills the game host of
America's yeah game night or whatever
it's a Jane Lynch is a lesbian I'm sorry
I'm sorry here's the thing and then they
went on to quote in the article that
because you identify with a certain you
know body type and you may not go out
for sports because you're not
identifying with that group or you're
afraid of being ridiculed so what does
it come back to you said it earlier it's
funding it's not the funding of this
study
it's the funding they cut out of school
it's shop classes when I went to junior
high you had a you had electric shop
metal shop wood shop
you had graphic art design you had used
to silkscreen shirts now somewhere in
there is a lesbian
you know Xanadu you know and quite
frankly if you were funding that the
lesbians could go through the shop
classes find something that was their
passion and go on to be the next imprint
revolution which by the way is on Pico
and they they're gonna sponsors I think
is what you're saying
well thinner or fatter is really is
really kind of a there would be higher
self esteem at any weight yeah so we
wouldn't be focused on why are they fat
as opposed to why don't they have
hobbies
there are lipstick lesbians too so you
know look I'm just making that point and
there are three quarters so you might
have 25 percent that's fine and then
there's the metrosexual gay guys and
then there's the bare gay guy I mean you
know this it's a population people yeah
you have in the formative years because
we keep you know again because we're
doing studies like this which aren't
this has got to be one of the dumbest
things I've ever heard ever ever
but it's because then the try hat people
you know the tea people will go now we
got to cut everything so you get like a
jarvis of prop 13 and they cut the stuff
that would help kids to identify with
new groups and to identify with new
things they like yeah that's what you
know you cut shop class well that's why
I wanted to do this segment because I
want people to see that yes this sounds
silly and we can make jokes about it but
to your point we do need science and all
that so last thought on this when I was
reading this I was also thinking this is
kind of like Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory like the NIH I feel like there's
just a lot of [ __ ] going on there that
we don't know about
and maybe we shouldn't know like maybe
they're working on the Everlasting
Gobstopper right now and we can't know
about it right now cuz it's all to that
that science thing so we kind of just
have to let them right we do have to
fund some of this and not know what's
going on kind of the thing is you know
the way it's supposed to work is you
elect people who oversee these things
people that you supposedly trust
we no longer realize the road we no
longer trust the people that oversee it
so therefore we no longer trust it if we
went back to the proposal the grant for
this study was that someone who's gonna
we're gonna cure lesbianism once we get
them thin you know once they have
options like you have to really look at
with what's behind this study which they
do not mention they they sort of like
put out a paper yeah I trust that you
know ninety percent of the scientists
out there have good intentions to to
find out you know things that are going
to help humanity as a whole I really do
but you know I don't know the NIH and
I'm sure there's a lot of politics and
all about and you know and yeah it's
ridiculous on paper and it could be
ridiculous and of course the media puts
it out there to make us all mad about it
all right let's talk about Psychopaths I
think a fitting way to end this show
with these two Psychopaths and I'm
sitting next to but first let's look at
the definition of psychopaths
psychopathy is a personality disorder
characterized by shallow emotions in
particular reduced fear stress tolerance
lacking empathy called heartedness
lacking guilt egocentricity superficial
character manipulative nasir
responsibility impulsivity and
antisocial behaviors such as parasitic
lifestyle and criminality now I bring
this up not because I just want to talk
about psychos but because Time magazine
had an interesting article on the type
of professions that kind of breed
Psychopaths versus the ones that don't
so let's take a look at that
okay and now here's where we're all
gonna be in trouble the ones that breed
Psychopaths II number one CEO I think
we're all gonna have fun with that we're
just gonna read a couple of them to
lawyer three media TV radio let's put
slash Internet there and then we're all
in trouble
salesperson surgeon journalist now you
can see most of these things with the
exception of police over these are
pretty well-paying jobs
general energy person that that's the
interesting one the whole bat line
that one now look at the ones that do
not breed psychopathy and this is really
fascinating so carried nurse therapist
crass person charity worker teacher
creative artist doctor accountant okay
my count is absolutely flip over yeah
I mean it we could also do this like we
could have like a little like a head of
like let's say Bill O'Reilly yeah and
you could just like like magnet you just
go well he's a CEO plume I think he's a
lawyer boom media TV radio and now that
one doesn't fit he's a sales person boom
I think he played a surgeon once on TV
boom
calls himself a journalist that's
depending you know literally look at all
the people we know that fit one through
three seven and this up for me because I
don't want to feel that we're
psychopaths we're all number three well
it's you know it's there's a lot of gray
area you know the other thing too they
had in this article was the list of
traits you know and how you could kind
of you know say the name of these traits
differently and I thought charismatic
was one and then superficial charm was
of the nice you know the kind of meaner
way of saying it person who can make
hard decisions could also be seen as the
person who has emotional poverty you
know so there there is a continuum here
and and I think during the day we we
swing between not psychopaths and not
you know blob of amoeba which I think is
the two extremes here we cycle between
these two things because we have
somewhat sometimes we have to make the
hard decision and sometimes we have to
be the one with the shoulder that you
cry on and and I think for many of us in
this business in particular we feel torn
because if you're in showbiz we know
it's cutthroat it is a psychopathic
industry it doesn't believe in caring
about your family your mental health
your physical health just as a worker in
it it will chew you up in stable chewy
will keep coming back tation everything
because we are creative artists and
we're looking for an outlet so you know
but the thing is when you look at these
CEOs and see the decisions they need to
make and see how some of them run their
companies and hedge fund guys to hedge
fund guys even scarier
that really when I first learned about
this like a couple years ago I learned
about this really just chilled me to the
bone to think wow we are like all of our
greatest MBA programs are training
people to be more psychopathic and less
it here for Humanity no wonder we're in
the tapering right now to that point
then isn't aren't these people the hedge
fund guys and the guys on Wall Street
that are doing all these you know I
don't even know what the words the
annuities and all the trickery all the
financial trickery and the derivative
that they're doing it at a computer so
they're not even seeing the human end of
it so does so does even we've talked a
lot about technologies today but that
even that it's now creeped into they
don't have to see the people that
they're [ __ ] over basically I just
remember that from American Psycho I
have to go return some videotapes yeah
everyone thought that guy was a pretty
upstanding ya know it's look it all it's
all connected as my mother would love to
say it's all connected
it's again a lack of analog you know you
don't have funding you you don't
identify people early enough because
you're not really interfacing with them
there's not enough social work being
done in the in the primary school system
to identify people that need help and
that need a little special extra
attention are you watching very closely
there then they're then pushed through
the system they have they have all of
the things on your list that they
haven't mastered and yet they learned
how to kind of mask them for it and
they'd start getting rewarded yeah
Puritan work ethic you know hard work
pull yourself up by your bootstraps
you're gonna be rewarded in the
afterlife that was the original concept
of that you're gonna be rewarded in the
afterlife so do what you have to do in
this you know in this area is you're
gonna be rewarded if you're successful
in the end oh and you know I'm more of a
reward you'll get it here kind of guy I
hope that's what I always hope
like the black-and-white nature of how
you know there was like two columns and
there was the left column the right
column you know could you start having
discussions like you know General George
Patton Psychopaths
you know like start to think about it in
the gray of that certain certain traits
certain ability to be emotionally dead
inside or cut off from every emotion
makes you effective at certain jobs and
in certain situations when you're you
know fighting World War two you can't
have everybody out there going so how do
you feel about this land minefield have
you think about it in not that we need
to breed Psychopaths but we can't just
think about like good or bad and that
they're all Patrick Bateman which looks
good on and then it's situational I mean
you know a therapist if you're dealing
with a client who's suicidal you're not
gonna be like let me give you how you're
like I'm sorry I'm putting you in for a
forty eight hold because you're gonna
hurt yourself yeah you know you have to
be the the dictator in that moment and
you have to be you know the cold and
have some emotional poverty you can't be
aching with your depressed patient you
know so it's very situational that's
interesting the idea that so for the for
the money guys they need the distance
and can just look at the computer so
they can screw the people they don't
know but for the the soldiers and the
military commanders they need the
reverse in a weird way does that what
does what does army because they can
pretend you look you know look at some
of the protein films but look at Full
Metal Jacket you know look at what that
process of that film was part of that
journey was taking this funny guy who
they called the Joker
Matthew Modine and just dehumanizing to
the point where in that fateful scene he
can draw down on that female sniper and
blow her away yeah you know that's the
journey to psyche psycho Psychopaths II
yeah you know that's interesting all
right so let's bring it home and talk
about money because there obviously is
some connection between all this and
money if you looked at the left-hand
column a lot of money there
right um the nurses not making that much
money the the therapists things like
that so how much of this is inherently
related to the quest for money I guess
all of it I think I said the culture you
know the culture supports more
psychopathic you are but you're not
killing and actually murdering people
the more likely you're gonna do well in
business I mean that's the way the
business model is set up there's not a
lot of humanity in in any I mean it's
funny because you know you look at
lawyers I mean there's a lot of great
lawyers who work for free and they're
there because they're trying to do good
and they're trying to bring actual
justice you know there's a lot of a lot
of bonus people on the left that left
column that do do it for the right
reasons but yeah this culture is set I
mean we watch football every weekend
[Laughter]
look you know think about it this way
you know if corporate let's go citizens
united if corporations are people maybe
we just have to have those corporations
deemed Psychopaths so for this week I am
Kelly Carlin ya know Dave Rubin she is
Kelly Carlin and with that he is and onh
add 9 binder there you go all right
thanks for watching guys their Twitter's
are right down below comment subscribe
all that fancy stuff and take a break
from the digital thing every now and
again but not but then don't watch us
there you go thanks guys
[Music]